françois bayrou est l'invité de soir 3
politique
la réforme des retraites est au coeur du
débat comment débloquer la situation
la lutte contre les déficits où trouver
l'argent et le modem où se situe-t-il
dans ce paysage
merci d'être avec nous françois bayrou
ce soir je rappelle que vous êtes
président du modem député des
pyrénées-atlantiques ancien ministre les
retraites d'abord beaucoup de monde hier
dans les rues est ce qu'il faut tout
remettre à plat comme l'a proposé
martine aubry par exemple je vais pas
respecté les règles habituelles de
l'interview c'est à dire que non pas du
tout c'est à dire que c'est important le
sujet que vous a brouillé mais il ya
deux sujets cette semaine qui sont
extraordinairement important et dont
personne n'a dit un mot alors en deux
phrases je vais les traiter parce que
ces sujets explique rapidement s'il veut
avoir des retraités certaines choses ne
soyez pas impatients c'est à dire mais
en attendant on va très bien y arriver
cette semaine pour la première fois dans
notre histoire depuis très très très
longtemps
la dette est devenu le premier poste du
budget mais sans rire lui important que
l'éducation mais on va y revenir
et la deuxième chose vous savez que il
ya des mouvements très importants en
europe parce que on pensait que la grèce
n'arriverait pas à payer déficit
que s'est il passé cette semaine la
chine a dit qu'elle rachèterait la dette
grecque
d'accord alors alors non mais si oui
c'est bien on va rire c est ce qu on va
parler quand même des retraites s'est
tassée cdh assez important pour que
d'accord on comprenne que là est la
véritable raison pour laquelle entre
autres nous devons faire la réforme des
retraites alors donc question est ce
qu'il faut à la suite des manifestations
d'hier remette tout à plat n'ont en
outre donné le temps de la discussion
non c'est pas il aurait fallu prendre le
temps de discussion avant mais au point
où nous en sommes arrivés après des mois
et des mois de crispation de tension
bien sûr on peut pas tout remettre à
plat et tout recommencer à zéro
il ya une chose à faire sur laquelle
monsieur chérèque au nom de la cfdt a
ouvert une porte
ce chérèque a dit écoutez peut-être on
peut pas tout avoir
mais il ya en tout cas une chose qu'on
peut faire c'est s'intéresser à ce sujet
sur lequel je suis intervenu comme vous
savez dès la première minute qui est la
question des 67 ans il dit a
naturellement une décision qui vise à
déplacer en huit ans sur huit années
d'un glissement de 60 à 62 ans l'âge de
départ du premier départ à la retraite
mais il ya une injustice colossale au
sur laquelle aujourd'hui je crois tout
le monde ouvre les yeux qui est que on
déplace à 67 ans l'âge où ceux qui n'ont
pas une carrière complète ont le droit
de faire valoir leurs droits oui mais ça
se disent n'est pas juste alors d'accord
et on a le sénat cette semaine où le
champ alors vous dites 67 ans
inacceptable en revanche vous vous
accepter l'idée de 62 ans est de 62 ans
au lieu de 60 c'est toujours aussi
impopulaire impopulaire d'ailleurs et
est-ce que ça n'est pas pénaliser ceux
qui ont les métiers les plus pénibles
qui veulent partir à 60 ans la peña la
pénibilité comme on dit c'est à dire le
le la chance offerte ou le leu
l'occasion offerte à ceux qui ont pu des
métiers pénibles physiquement et peut
être moralement de partir avant les
autres ça va être traitée cette semaine
au sénat et j'espère bien traités mais
pour moi ce qui est injuste ce qui
pénalise en mai 62 ans c'est injuste
ben écoute et on peut pas rester comme
on est nous avons une population dont
l'âge s'allonge
nous avons de plus en plus de retraités
et de moins en moins de cinq ans et ceux
qui voudraient partir à 60 parce qu'ils
ont des métiers difficiles non parce que
pas vrai si c'est pas vrai aussi ces
centres qui ont des métiers difficiles
il est normal qu'on leur offre une
possibilité de partir avant je crois que
ça va être fait du moins j'espère que ça
va l'être tout le monde s'accorde à le
reconnaître mais alors honnêtement je
dis pas que ce soit agréable d'aller
d'ici 2018
à 62 ans c'est pas agréable mais c'est
raisonnable ne peuvent pas on peut pas
vivre avec plus de 30 milliards par an
d'argent qu'on emprunte c'est à dire
qu'on met sur le dos des enfants pour
payer les retraites des actifs
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez bien compte
que c'est impossible comme indiqué hier
les syndicats vont se revoir demain pour
voir quelle suite ils vont donner à tout
ça
il ya déjà une journée d'action prévue
pour le 12 octobre si le conflit se
durcisse si la situation se bloque ce
sera la faute de qui du gouvernement des
syndicats
d'abord j'espère qu'elle ne se bloquera
pas parce qu'il ya cette semaine une
délibération au sénat c'est encore le
parlement qui vote la loi en france ça
c'est pas le gouvernement qui décide
c'est le parlement l'assemblée nationale
a émis un vote on a d'ailleurs failli
sur un amendement que je présentais
conserver les 65 me lance je sais qu'il
écrirait orientale du jeu sièges
j'espère que ça ne se produira pas et
que tout le monde aura le mouvement de
conscience nécessaire pour dire ya au
moins un point dur sur lequel tout le
monde est d'accord ce point dur ne coûte
pas si cher je l'éprouvé à l'assemblée
au moins sur ce point
faisons un geste juste une chose une
idée qui fait son chemin c'est l'idée
d'un référendum comme l'a dit arnaud
montebourg aujourd'hui sur les retraites
ma proposition c'est puisque le
gouvernement en est à contester et à
compter en centaines de milliers de
moins je propose qu'il soumette son
projet au référendum et là sera un vrai
comptage propositions pour l'instant
rejetée par les contrats les voit on
verra qui est pour et qui est contre
alors un référendum sur les retraites
pour ou contre
comme vous savez j'ai été le premier à
émettre cette idée au moment de la
campagne présidentielle de 2007
mon idée était elle reste valable
prenons aujourd'hui franchement ça
paraît si mal engagée
mais l'idée était discutée en prenant le
temps de la discussion
dégageons une loi et soumettons la loi
au référendum car le référendum alj
avantages que ça n'est plus dans la rue
seulement que ça se jouer dans les yeux
mais c'est trop tard aujourd'hui pour un
référendum
oui je n'y crois peu pour tout vous dire
on va parler maintenant l'élection
présidentielle c'est en 2012 dans un an
et demi une date qui est dans toutes les
têtes dans la vôtre aussi évidemment
françois bayrou patrice machuret du
service politique va nous rejoindre du
service politique de france 3 pour nous
en dire plus parce que la droite l'idée
d'un 21 avril où l'ump serait éliminée
est envisagé patrice bonsoir oui m'enfin
bon alors c'est le scénario catastrophe
à nicolas sarkozy battu dès le premier
tour trahi par les siens à droite des
candidats prédateurs pourraient
siphonner le réservoir de l'ump c'est
mathématique hervé morin vous connaissez
bien prendrait des voix au centre droit
christine boutin séduire elle est
catholique déçu nicolas dupont aignan
rattraperait des souverainistes perdu
jean louis borloo les écolo de droite et
bien sûr dominique de villepin se
régaleraient duvivier gaulliste social
raboter grignoter le socle du chef de
l'état finirait par s'effondrer dès le
premier tour et sa chasse aux électeurs
du fn ne comporterait pas les pertes
pires marine le pen reprendrait des
couleurs
d'où ce chiffon rouge agité par l'elysée
pour ne pas finir comme la gauche en
2002 il faut taire les ambitions à
droite les morin borloo boutin et même
villepin se retrouvent ainsi en position
d'accusé un peu des brutus capable
d'anéantir lempire ump alors résisteront
ils à cette pression l'avenir le dira
marine le pen en attendant continue sa
route elle veut ramener la droite au
minimum en 2007 la médaille de bronze
était pour vous françois bayrou
en 2012 le troisième homme pourrait être
une femme
d'où ma question françois bo est ce que
vous y croyez à ce 21 avril inversée je
crois pas un mot de ce que venait de
raconter
donc c'est là c'est la propagande
habituelle qu'on connaît toujours avant
les élections coûtent les choses sont
simples y aura un candidat de droite est
selon moi ça sera nicolas sarkozy il y
aura un candidat de gauche ps et ce sera
on verra au terme de la discussion
qu'ils auront en tout cas c'est un
candidat socialiste qui sera là et il y
aura un candidat du centre et un seul
vous êtes prononcée en 2006 avant
l'élection pour une dose de
proportionnelle à l'assemblée nationale
pour permettre d'avoir finalement des
députés front national à l'assemblée est
ce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous voyez la
remontée alors en tout cas ce serait une
des conséquences mais la remontée
aujourd'hui de marine le pen ferait qu'
évidemment il y aura des députés fn est
ce que vous vous maintenez encore saisi
la proposition d'un sip élémentaire
c'est que tous les citoyens français ont
le droit d'être représentés à égalité à
l'assemblée nationale au parlement tous
et qu'ils soient du centre de droite de
gauche plus à droite ou plus à gauche ça
ne leur enlève pas leur citoyenneté
alors il est donc et donc je dis que en
effet le jour où on voudra qu'il y ait
une assemblée nationale qui ne soit pas
à la remorque du pouvoir comme elle est
aujourd'hui scandaleusement alors il
faudra que l tienne sa légitimité du
peuple dans sa diversité
une haie au moins pour la moitié des
sièges parce que j'admets qu'il faut une
majorité je vais vous poser une question
parle beaucoup du remaniement
gouvernemental nicolas sarkozy a ouvert
à gauche s'il voulait ouvrir au centre
est ce que vous seriez partant il ne
peut y avoir participation à un
gouvernement que quand on met en accord
avec la politique suivie
comprenez sam j'ai donc vous êtes en
désaccord vous savez j'ai refusé à de
multiples reprises ce genre d'ouverture
d'offres pourquoi parce que depuis le
premier jour je vois venir ce qui est en
train de se produire sous nos yeux
c'est à dire un certain nombre
d'orientations
ce qui amène la france à ne résoudre
aucun des problèmes qui sont les siens
et au contraire à perdre de son image et
de sa légitimité alors le remaniement
c'est pas pour tout de suite on va voir
maintenant les temps forts de la semaine
politique à venir est alors pour
l'agenda mardi après midi on l'a dit au
sénat bagarre de procédures en vue pour
la réforme des retraites la gauche
dépose 700 amendements pas moins et le
matin c'est martine aubry elle même qui
vient galvaniser ses troupes lors de la
réunion du groupe socialiste
vendredi nicolas sarkozy s'envole vers
le vatican peut être pour faire son mea
culpa
le pape benoît 16 n'apprécie guère on le
sait l'attitude du gouvernement français
envers les populations roms enfin les
socialistes samedi vont refaire le monde
après avoir annulé hier leur convention
sur la sécurité
ils maintiennent celle qui était prévue
donc samedi prochain sur l'europe et
l'international et on imagine sépareront
de terrorisme un tout dernier mot
françois bayrou on peut dire un mot
normand n'a pas le temps vraiment à tout
dernier mot françois fillon a dit ce
soir que la question du bouclier fiscal
et de l'isf n'était plus un tabou qu'on
pourrait le revoir ça avant 2011 il faut
commencer par quoi par le bouclier
fiscal ou l'impôt sur la fortune
bon les deux sont liés mais en tout cas
le bouclier fiscal est une atteinte à
tous les principes raisonnable et au
principe d'égalité ou d'équité devant
l'impôt normalement l'impôt en france
s'est bâti de manière que ceux qui sont
les plus riches participent un peu plus
que ceux qui sont les plus beaux il faut
arrêter le beau gosse qui a tout le
bouclier fiscal et il faut que ceux qui
vous écoute
nous nous écouterons je sache c'est fait
pour que ceux qui sont les plus riches
on vient de le voir avec madame
bettencourt paie moins
donc il faut supprimer suite salaire
moyen ou au contraire les cyclos et où
qu'ils allaient donc ça il faut le
changer et je crois que ça devrait aller
avec une réforme profonde de l' isf
croit d'ailleurs qu'il ya des solutions
très simples mais à mon avis ce sera un
des sujets de la prochaine élection
présidentielle
on verra ça d'un claquement de doigts
simplement parce que untel ou untel a
fait une déclaration on vous reverra
tous les équilibres des finances et des
impôts qui est en jeu ça mérite qu'on
tenait une refont d'assises 2012
vous aurez un titre aquila merci
beaucoup françois mercier de mahmur
quelques minutes ce soir